eric en toile alice est parti on a un
truc de folie appuyé sur twitter alors
il faudrait que vous connaissiez
donc à mon compte twitter ou au compte
de tpm port de syrie j'envoie à twitter
maintenant avec on le voit la caméra est
ce que vous avez j'envoie c'est un
tweeter venu du futur c'est une
prédiction chose a mis d'accord et pmp
officiel cyril hanouna des huit magie
observé c'est quoi la prédiction c'est
une prédiction il a écrit magie observer
notre tp mp intensément exclusivement
langoureusement je vais t'expliquer
pourquoi cette prédiction dans quelques
instants j'imagine qu'il va apparaître
sur les écrans que ralentie savoir on
est sur dix huit ans il arrive mais
moyennement alors on y va un petit peu
une petite photo comme ça on l'a sur les
écrans alors là j'ai un petit peu
comptabilisé si vous les amis que vous
avez sur twitter les uns les autres
alors bien sûr et nohra deux cent trente
sept mille personnes te suivent tous les
jours fort c'est à dire c'est une ville
entière les gens adorent
isabelle 40 2006 gas est une sous
préfecture en 335 1000 m2 180 milles
pour thierry alors c'est quand même très
tangible 72 mille fans de ragga c'est
quand même c'est camille regarde la
tronche photos de cabine il n'est pas le
mec est photogénique tous les angles
sont bons c'est un acteur de cinéma
c'est extraordinaire et jean-michel
342000 follower commun il ya des vieux
sur twitter après ta françois françois
442 non mais pas 2000
ça fait gagner
privé le mec n'a pas de téléphone et
berna alors là ça 90 100 90 mais pas de
1000 non plus le mec toujours au minitel
en tout cas demandé mon cher s'il de
mélanger ces cas là ça y'a pas de marco
dos on sait pas lesquels et lequel on va
utiliser cette parution ce magazine cet
hebdo extraordinaire études et langer
s'il te plaît sur sur la table comme ça
voilà donc on sait pas où se cachent
faut qu'elle mélange quelle boîte et
quelle dextérité du de la première fois
qu'on me dit ça alors c'est pas grave
tiens tu mélanges et sûrs mais en
dessous le journal je veux pas savoir
l'accord sont mélangés on va mélanger ce
cas quelle heure tu peux mais on sait
maintenant tu peux te voilà donc on est
bien d'accord je ne sais parler où sont
les qu'un peu seule chose à dire on va
refaire peut-être on va peut-être vivre
un petit moment d'actualité
ça me rappelle quelque chose on ne fait
pas des vannes comme ça fait drôle quand
même bien je vais carte postale comme ça
l'est ce qui serait drôle c'est que tu
mets ta main et je le redis contraire
d'un bac ont fait des questions vous
avez aujourd'hui parce que je veux vous
expliquer j'ai tous mes un truc avec
nagui cet après-midi et et nagui pareil
et il lui a remis un mec qui voulait
absolument que je m'offre un garage au
jour que c'est vrai sinon j'étais que
jamais les magiciens dans l'après midi
ils voulaient facile là bas j'étais avec
nagui bien quand on est d'accord je ne
sais pas où sur un car postal
je pique comme ça d'accord et la
première carte postale sur laquelle va
tomber ça sera donc là près de la
prédiction de ce soir j'espère on
retient c'est à dire que là on a trouvé
on a eu plusieurs cartes un état grave
on apprendre la première d'accord la
personne choisie ce soir au ice bernard
montiel bernard montiel 190 personnes
regardent maintenant ce tweet venu du
futur
ouais alors cette chemise tpm paix
officielle des huit tout ça ce soir
regardez bien si on prend la phrase qui
est ici il ya une lettre une première
réplique manche alliance intrigue m ou
magie au observer notre nom le t2t pnr
est le i2 attention le e d'exclusivement
et le l de l'engouement 20e au lt iae
elle monte diable
c'est très bien
je sais pourquoi alors je viens de
comprendre pourquoi je t'ai pas dans les
capte cette version père le toit à
kaduna parce que t'es trop fort